Ignacio casis the president of the Swiss
Confederation thank you for talking to
DW today's conference comes and builds
up on the Lugano principles the
conference that took place in July in
Switzerland this is not a normal donor
conference as president s Chandler
Schultz said why does Ukraine need
another conference without Financial
pledges by the ones who are coming to
this conference the short answer could
be because there are so many open
questions that needs to be clarified and
need to be answered and the longer
answer is in Lugano we started a process
with a kickoff conference which defined
the seven principles on the base of
which the Recon the recovery process
should be built on and now to answer the
question that are posed by this recovery
process we need to have scientific
evidence we need to learn from the
history what less person said did we
learn from the history in the
reconstruction plan in the marsh plan
and so on and this conference is a kind
of scientific conference to clarify the
open questions
you recently went to Ukraine you went to
cave and you want Ukraine to see
Switzerland as a reliable partner how do
you expect that considering that citing
um neutrality you don't Supply weapons
to Ukraine there's something that
they're looking forward and have been
asking for for months now well the fact
to be neutral is a reason more to be
seen as a reliable partner since we
cannot deliver a weapons we cannot be
part of the military and of the war then
we have to be more present on the
humanitarian assistance on the
Diplomatic efforts in order to one find
a solution to to a ceasefire to stop the
war but what are the immediate needs now
is to be ready to face the coming winter
and these the correct answer is the
humanitarian assistance we have to
deliver material know-how technology and
electricity uh infrastructure has been
destroyed by by bombs and by missiles so
we can make a contribution to repair and
to re-establish the necessary
infrastructure in order for the people
to pass the winner
Moscow says it does not see Switzerland
as a neutral partner anymore what does
that mean for the role that you could
play as a possible me data and not only
when we look at the role of the war in
Ukraine but also the talks about the war
in Syria that are happening in Geneva
well we are acting in this uh War
exactly the same way like we were acting
in every other Wars we never delivered
weapons or troops or let our territory
be used for uh for foreign troops and so
on this is our role this is our we act
according to international law and
international law on neutrality are
clear have been clear for more than 100
years this doesn't mean that we don't
not stand for the values that are
written in our constitution neutrality
doesn't mean indifference and we belong
to the Western values to the Western
families and we are geographically there
where we are in the middle of Europe we
are a European country and this is
compatible with neutrality
how would you define the difference
between neutrality and being indifferent
to what's happening in Ukraine with
countries for example not condemning the
war in Russia can they say it's also
neutrality or would they be indifference
because yeah maybe they're siding with
Russia on that side I would use the the
word of indifference or of positioning
of other countries neutrality is a legal
word based upon international law
neutrality is not just a
feeling or or a moment in time
neutrality is a permanent neutrality
it's a weapon neutrality we have an Army
in Switzerland and we we are acting
according this international law
nevertheless we adopted EU sanctions
because we are convinced that this was
the right instrument to stop this war to
to to let Russia stop the war probably
not very in the short term but in the
middle term and the this is the way that
Switzerland choose to go but the same
way we already choose to go with other
Wars we have adopted many many sanctions
from the U.N and from the Europe before
these sanctions do you see any possible
peace talks between Ukraine and Russia
happening in the near future could they
for example happen in Switzerland
principally yes of course but in in this
very moment it is difficult to imagine
such a diplomatic effort because now
it's time for the military part of the
both parts are convinced they can win
the war and the space for diplomacy is
in this very moment really I don't think
it is given
the president of the Swiss Confederation
thank you so much for talking to DW
thank you too